[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonjour bonjour en
position voile académie des dalons vie
chère
à peine arrivé ce matin là que la 22e
promotion réalise son rituel de départ
pour leur première action on va vous
remettre donc le matériel de collecte
mais aussi le matériel d'hygiène
principalement pour justement être à
l'abri dans cette rencontre avec le
public
séverine voudrait devenir réceptionniste
et morgane agents de sécurité c'est donc
avec plaisir qu'elle se mobilise sur ce
projet ce travail plutôt en confiance
mon confiance et et aboutit heureux et à
l'avenir trouver quand même quelque
chose en fait part du projet pro espère
avec les personnes professionnels awa de
l'aide pour me sentir
l'action était préparé donc avec mes
collègues en termes de développement
personnel et d'affirmation de soi ça a
été donc une des préparatifs avec des
mises en situation afin que ces jeunes
sortent de leur zone de confort ces
jeunes ont l'occasion de développer ce
qu'on appelle donc leur sentiment
d'utilité sociale
un ressenti donc il est très important
dans leur développement personnel
[Musique]
depuis plus de quatre ans la croix rouge
et partenaires de l'académie des dalons
avec anciennement des stagiaires en
service civique ou encore des maraudes
à peine arrivés les jeunes femmes se
dispersent sur ce grand parking
seul face au quotidien de cette foule le
consommateur rythmée par leurs habitudes
pas facile de briser la glace qui est de
créer un échange certainement gagnant
gagnant parce que les jeunes libyens ils
prennent une expérience dans la
rencontre des personnes sylvain que la
timidité
ils arrivent à faire des choses à se
remettre en question et nous met de côté
on a besoin toujours des bénévoles ou
deux personnes
motivés pour nous aider dans notre
action quotidienne
[Musique]
diaz le parrain de cette opération donne
du courage aux jeunes bénévoles et de
l'élan aux donateurs
[Musique]
no doubt ça veut dire aucun doute parce
que j'ai vraiment cette prise de
conscience que on a tous à notre niveau
la possibilité d'agir et je crois que
c'est lorsqu'on a été dans la situation
compliquée qu'on est en mesure de
comprendre à quel point notre aide à
notre petit niveau peut changer quelque
chose dans la vie de quelqu'un se
produire en produisant est clairement le
sens de cette action et la mécanique a
l'air de fonctionner fait à noter un
sonar et ignorer solide et amène adot
bas
la fois banale préfèrent eux vivent de
cette partie et parfums compte excès de
lapointe tout un rôle pour jouer nous
tout chacun doute manière